you said that uh there's something
healing about being in an empty hotel
room M with no attachments except your
suitcase you know a lot of people talk
about hotel rooms
being a fundamentally lonely experience
but you're saying it's it's healing it's
healing yeah cuz I just get to sit there
and not worry about all this stuff that
like this these meaningless attachments
I've got my suitcase with my NE
Necessities or my three suitcases
sometimes and
uh I can just sit there and meditate and
just be with myself and it's so awesome
and usually like you plan your touring
for like you know you you you kind of
get the business aspect of things taken
care of in advance so you can kind of
just really be flowing daytoday on a
tour and it's a great
feeling it's funny because this last
tour that I did we didn't have hotels
every night we had hotels maybe like
once a
week and I I hadn't done that before
usually it's I'm frequently in hotels so
I didn't get that space that I'm really
used to getting you missed them I very
much missed it and had to be very
creative
and I ended up
like going into the back Lounge when
everyone was asleep and like meditating
back there or like before everyone woke
up um and I actually like joined there
was like an online Meditation Retreat
that was happening it was like 12 hours
a day of Silent meditations that happens
once a year and I love this this
particular group of people and they knew
I was on tour so they're like just join
when you can and so I was on the tour
doing The Meditation Retreat at the same
time it was so fun it was so fun because
I was like in the back Lounge the boss
is like moving around like this my
laptop the zoom is like and I'm just
like sitting like meditating it was like
yeah this is the silence so they
they're all connected through zoom and
just doing s 12 12 hours a day yeah
that's cool these particular Retreats
that I started doing it's not straight
silent there are you know silent sits
every hour for 50 minutes and then
there's some talks and like these people
that I've been working with are really
cool because they're
integrating um spiral Dynamics into zen
and it's like the coolest combination
what's spiral Dynamics like Ken Wilbur
do you know Ken Wilbur integral theory
yes can you explain a little bit so he I
vaguely know of him because of kind of
this notion
that everything is one like everything
is integrated that every
field has truths and falsehoods and we
should integrate the
truths yeah it's hard to explain how it
applies to this type of meditation
because it's in the the guided parts of
the meditation that this whole like
holonic theory is like brought in about
like transcending and including
every aspect of your being MH um because
he talks about like levels of
development and like it in Consciousness
and how like this applies to like every
single religion or non-religion that
there are these levels of development
and from all that go all the way up to
Enlightenment and no matter what you
start off with it could be you know
Christianity Buddhism vidanta doesn't
matter like anything then I just like I
like it when everything is and everyone
is taken into account it doesn't matter
what you're coming from that there is a
way to to be self-realized
self-actualized there are
self-actualized beings from all walks of
life with very very different paths
There's No One path I mean in this
particular Retreat I do there's like a
lot of Silent sits and then there's some
guided
meditations um but this I I've tried a
lot of different Avenues and they're all
great so I wouldn't just say just try
this one thing like I've studied like
the shads like with Vidant teaches and
like gone through those texts for months
and months and stayed at monasteries and
like how they break it down makes total
sense to my mind and heart and like my
more importantly than my mind like my
inner knowing like it
resonates inner knowing yeah because
like your mind is like the thinking tool
like it's it's not you you're not your
mind you're not your thoughts you're not
your body you know so it's like just the
you like that knowing that you have
that's kind of when something resonates
there that's usually when you go with
something